for today
um we're going to recap a little bit
from what we talked about last week from
the metal learning problem setup and
black box meta learning and then we're
going to get into optimization-based by
learning where we're actually going to
be embedding an optimization process
inside another optimization process
um and this is a part of part of what
we'll be talking about today is part of
homework too and so it should also be
useful for uh for for that
um great and then yeah by the end of the
lecture
um you should have a sense for kind of
the basics of optimization-based meta
learning techniques and how to implement
them in things like pytorch and also
some of the trade-offs between Black Box
metal learning and optimization based my
learning
cool um so to start your recap uh from
last lecture or some of the previous
lectures we've talked about multitask
learning and transfer learning and we
introduced this notion of the meta
learning problem statement which is a
kind of a form of transfer learning
where our goal is
having been given a set of training
tasks we want to more quickly or more
proficiently solve a new task
and we looked at this kind of running
example meta learning problem where we
have uh we're trying to do five-way
classification we're given one example
from each of the five different classes
as this really tiny training data set
and our goal is to be able to predict
the label for new examples as being
among one of those five classes
and the way that we did this is we set
up a set of tasks that look a lot like
the kind of tasks that we'll see at meta
test time and so these were our training
tasks and we performed meta training on
these tasks because we're trying to
learn how to quickly learn each of these
training tasks such that when we're
given a new task at metatest time we can
quickly learn that
um and this was an example an image
classification but you can also replace
uh replace this example with other
machine learning problems
um great and then one of the big topics
of lecture on Wednesday last week was
how we can actually solve these few shot
learning problems with a black box
neural network where we basically just
pass in the training data set into
um something like a recurrent neural
network have that neural network
possibly output a set of parameters for
that task and then we make predictions
for new inputs for that task by passing
that through the neural network with
those parameters we also talked about a
second version of this where
um it's not explicitly outputting the
parameters of an entire neural network
it's simply just giving you for example
another hidden state of that RNN and
then you can just again pass that
through the uh the last module or the
last time step of the RNN
um so this kind of takes this has this
more general form where we're going to
be passing in a training data set and a
test input into some function and we're
going to be making a corresponding
prediction
this method was great and that it's very
expressive you can represent lots of
different learning algorithms with these
large black box neural networks but they
could also be somewhat challenging to
optimize and that's maybe something that
you came across in uh in homework one if
you've gotten started on that
so in this lecture we're going to be
thinking about other ways to try to
represent this function that goes from a
training data set to a set of task
parameters
and in particular
we know something a little bit about
machine learning so you can think of
this RNN is trying to mimic a learning
process and instead of trying to just
have to throw a block box neural network
at this we could actually take a little
bit about what we know about machine
learning and actually apply that
structure to this function and try to
actually treat this function f as an
optimization procedure
so that's what we'll really be focusing
on today
so
um
in particular what we can do is we're
basically going to replace this RNN on
the top left with some form of
optimization process
and in particular we're going to focus
on optimization on gradient-based
optimization so
instead of putting these examples into a
RNN we can instead pass it we can
actually run gradient descent on these
examples in order to get a
set of task specific parameters
now um the key idea here is that we're
going to be embedding this gradient
descent optimization inside a broader
optimization process The Meta training
process
and
then the key question is what actually
are we going to be what are the meta
parameters what are we going to be kind
of meta training in this process
and
there's a number of different free
parameters of this process but we'll
focus on to start is a scenario where we
are optimizing for the initial
parameters of this neural network such
that running gradient descent on a few
examples gives us a good set of task
specific parameters for that task and
for other tasks
now
um why might this make sense
so if we go back to a couple lectures
ago we were talking about fine-tuning
and we would take us at a pre-trained
parameters Theta and run gradient
descent initialized with those
pre-trained parameters
and we found that uh fine-tuning can
actually work much better than learning
from scratch so we see that the green
and orange lines are much lower they
have much lower error than the blue
lines
um but they also don't do great in the
few shot regime and so essentially you
can think of this as trying to optimize
for a set of pre-trained parameters such
that we can actually do very well in the
future regime unlike if we were just
going to pre-train with uh with
something like supervised learning
um so in particular let's start to
formulate what this looks like as an
objective so
um fine-tuning is what we want to be
able to do at test time on our small
small training set for our new task
um and so what we can do is we can take
um one step of gradient descent we could
also imagine more than one step but
we'll start with a simplifying case of
one step of gradient descent
this will be used to get parameters for
task I after fine-tuning on the data set
for task I
and then once we have those parameters
we will evaluate how good those
parameters are
on new examples
specifically examples in the test data
set for that task
and then we'll essentially optimize for
the set of pre-trained parameters such
that this one step of gradient descent
is generalizing well to new examples
um and of course we won't just do this
over one task we'll do this over
all of the tasks that we have available
to us
and so this is essentially what our uh
what our objective is going to look like
for these um this optimization based
metal learning process
um so the key idea here is to try to
learn a parameter Vector an initial
parameter Vector Theta that transfers
very nicely with only a few examples
um I mentioned that this is an example
for this one gradient step but in
practice you could also put multiple
gradient steps in this inner loop here
um and it will
the equation will get a little bit
longer but this conceptual uh aspect of
it is the same
okay so
um
from here we can now that we have
our objective we can actually write out
what this looks like as an algorithm
so again we can think of the same
uh three-way One-Shot classification
problem that we considered in the last
lecture were basically different
different tasks will correspond to
classifying digits from different
alphabets uh in this case you could sort
of think of a different alphabets as
only having potentially three characters
and the first step again will be to
sample a task this will correspond to
three different characters
then the next step will be to sample
a couple images per character
and this will allow us to basically give
us a training data set and a test set
for that task
and so in particular
we might have x equals a
B
and c and Y equals 0 1 2 and then also
this will be our
um our training data set and then
likewise
a b
C
and this will be our
the test set for this task
zero one two
and so before what we did is we just
passed the train data set through a
neural network instead what we're going
to do is
[Music]
um
I guess it'll be a step zero here which
is to
randomly
initialize our meta parameters data
and then what the step three is going to
do is it's going to
take one gradient descent step on our
training data set
so we will start with our the current
value of our meta parameters then run
gradient descent
on our
three training examples and so I'll just
write this as
something like this
this will give us
a set of parameters Phi I
and then once we have these parameters
we will then
take our test examples run that through
our neural network with parameters Phi I
to get a corresponding prediction and so
for example we'll be looking at FYI of
of this example here
that will give us a corresponding
prediction
and then we'll compare that prediction
to the corresponding label to get how
well this neural network is generalizing
to new examples and from there we'll
then back propagate all the way back
into the initial parameter vectors Theta
in order to update our meta parameters
and so
in particular
we'll have an update on Theta which will
be based off of the
how well
Phi I is doing on your
held out examples detest for task guy
so this will be based off of ultimately
the gradient of this
cool
um now one other thing that I'll mention
here is
um
I guess I should maybe
well yeah actually sorry after after
step four then you'll go back to step
one and repeat and continuously update
um Theta based on
this value right here
so this is the full meta training
algorithm
um one thing that I'll mention here is
here we're going to be optimizing for
some set of initial parameters but you
could also optimize for other parts of
the feed or Loop learning process as
well for example you could optimize for
the learning rate here as well
um
and uh you could optimize with respect
to some weights applied to the data
points or something like that
um
yeah so this is the gist of that any
questions on the metatrading process
yeah I'm slightly confused about how
like Phi I and Theta are related to each
other so at step three you
um you get Phi I from just modifying
data but for step four you are updating
because they're using the gradient
obtained through thought yeah right on
okay
so that's the like the internet yeah
exactly so you can think of step three
as the inner loop of this process
because it's running the learning
process to get running the learning
process on a task for um task I and then
you can think of uh step four as this
kind of outer loop objective where we're
actually going to be
differentiating through the inner loop
process in order to figure out what
would have been a better initialization
that would have allowed me to better
generalize with this small data set
theater Loop could also be more than one
gradient stepping also be a few gradient
steps yeah
so the question is is this similar to
things like bootstrap your own latent
and offline and online processes I'm not
it's been I'm
it's I'm a little bit Rusty on the
details of by ol we will
um next week talk about unsupervised
pre-training methods and talk a little
bit about how those relate to my
learning method
yeah
it's different from my free black box uh
learning algorithms from last week
because for example if data in this case
were the parameters of an rnm then we
end up with something big
similar to what we have last week
yeah so the key difference with the
black box method so this is the and
black is the optimization based approach
the key step for the key difference for
the block box approach is really step
three and so the difference with step
step three is instead of actually
obtaining Phi I through gradient descent
we obtained Phi I
um by running it through a neural
network and so there was a neural
network I can't remember if I named it
FRG in the previous lecture but there's
a neural network that took his input the
training data points for the task and
outputted the parameters and now instead
of just passing this through a neural
network we're going to be running
gradient descent initialized at The Meta
parameters data
foreign
between tasks are different
um yeah so you could certainly have
different loss functions for different
tasks what you would do in that case is
l i you have basically have a l would be
kind of you'd have a different loss
function for different tasks and so
um you just need to use that that loss
function here and also here
and everything would all still work out
yeah so the question is how do you make
sure that forgetting doesn't happen as
you Loop through these tasks
um it may not be as good at uh kind of
the first task once after you've kind of
gone through the other tasks and really
the key thing here is that um when you
actually sample a task you may also
instead of sampling just one task you
may want to sample a mini batch of tasks
and this will actually give you a
gradient that isn't just or a better
gradient that isn't just for one task
it's for multiple
um you may ultimately get um a little
bit of forgetting insofar as like SGD
will kind of forget some some data
points for example
um but having a mini batch have a large
enough batch size can certainly help
with that
yeah
so the
this last time we were taking loss over
the query said but this time we'll be
taking loss of the support set and train
it instantly
um so what
the the
fourth step is still with respect to the
query set the the test
yeah so the third step is really where
the difference is and so it is running a
gradient step on the support set before
we are also using the support set in the
Black Box metal learning approach and we
are passing that into F Theta and so
yeah one key difference is here we're
actually taking sort of taking a
gradient step on both the support set
and the query set
um the uh
yeah but the key step is is kind of is
the difference between three if if you
basically just put this into three then
you get exactly the Black Box approach
that we had last week
so one other thing that might help a
little bit with um some intuition here
is that
you can think of theta as this set of
meta parameters that's being meta
learned and if you think about
Phi I star being the optimal parameter
Vector for task I
then you can think of meta training as
this really thick black line
where when you're at this point in the
Mediterranean process if you take a
gradient step with respect to task three
you're quite far from the optimum for
task three
um and likewise for other tasks and as
you kind of continue the meta training
process ultimately at the end of the
Mediterranean process you want to be at
a a place in the landscape where if you
take a gradient stop with respect to
toss three you're very close to task
three if you take a greatest type with
respect to task two you're very close to
a good parameter Vector for task two
so does me give you a little bit of a
kind of a visual depiction of the meta
training process
now one thing I will note about this
diagram that can potentially be a little
bit misleading is there isn't just a
single Optimum
um for any given task and so it's
actually going to be more of a actually
a large part of the parameter space for
any one task and your goal is to try to
find a part of the landscape where if
you take a gradient step
um you can get to a region that's good
for that task parameter rather than just
a single space
[Music]
um
yeah that's the gist of it in principle
this may
um in this diagram it kind of looks like
it's almost averaging the task
parameters
um in practice you may get something
like that in practice you may also be in
scenarios where you're actually pretty
far from the average
um and uh but where kind of a gradient
step will take you fairly far and on
that note I think it's worth mentioning
that this learning right here Alpha
um in practice will be much larger than
a typical learning rate that you might
use
um because you want to be able to
actually go pretty far and actually be
able to kind of Traverse very far in the
parameter space for different tasks
um
so certainly this does uh kind of look a
lot like a hyper parameter optimization
except where you're optimizing the full
initial parameters rather than just slow
learning rate your question was can you
also do hyper paramed optimization with
this or
like that
just making doing optimization
yeah so you could certainly consider
using hyper parameter optimization
techniques for learning the
initialization unfortunately a lot of
them are designed for optimizing a very
low dimensional set of hyper parameters
like one hyper parameter or five hyper
parameters and the initial parameters of
a neural network may be millions of
hyper parameters and so a lot of those
methods won't scale well to such
high-dimensional things and that's why
that's why in this case we're actually
going to be differentiating through the
learning process and using gradients but
there are there's a lot of ideas that
are transferable between the two
literatures
yeah so here we are taking loss with
respect to the near train right in the
third step so uh what is loss here
really because we concatenate the image
and label right when we pass in and then
we will we are obviously trying to find
the loss with respect to the training so
set levels again that's outputted by the
network
yeah great question so in books metal
learning we were concatenating we were
passing in both the image and the label
into the network here
um when we run this inner loop we're
going to have a model
um
we're gonna have a Model F Theta um
that's a kind of a neural network model
and we're going to be only passing as
input the
kind of the training examples into this
we're not going to be passing in the
labels and then we're going to get a
corresponding prediction and then
the this loss function right here l i
for Theta di train this is going to
equal the sum over examples
x i y i
in D train I of
um I guess if it's something like
regression you'll have something like y
hat train I minus y train I
um if it's classification you'll have
something more like a cross-entropy loss
uh and so this is um
this is this is kind of the definition
of this loss function and this is how
you're going to get the gradient and so
you're not actually going to be passing
in the labels into the network but the
labels will still come into play when
you're comparing the predictions from
the the model to the ground truth
predictions foreign
yeah we'll talk about pros and cons of
black box versus optimization based uh
towards the end
[Music]
yeah because it'll also be learning
right here too
in general
uh yeah it's a great question so do we
need to carefully schedule it uh
it is a hyper parameter um and you do
need to pick it carefully if you pick it
to be too large that it may be very
difficult like the great the updates may
be just way too large if you pick
something too small it may have trouble
actually differentiating and getting to
different parameter vectors for
different tasks uh and so it's important
to pick something that's that has a
middle ground the other thing that you
can do is you can optimize it as part of
um as part of step four as well and what
um what approaches have found is that
it's actually helpful to optimize a
different value of the learning rate for
different layers or even for different
parameters rather than having a single
learning rate for all the parameters and
this is because some parameters
especially biases like to have a very
large learning rate and others like to
have a very small learning rate and if
you try to optimize for a single
learning rate for all of them then they
find a middle ground that isn't
um
isn't good for the weights
if you do optimize a different Alpha for
these different for the different layers
it does actually end up being quite
stable
yeah
can we add a there before regularization
can we add a term for regularization so
yeah this all function
um the soft function could
also include a regularization term one
thing often actually one reason or one
interesting thing here to note here is
oftentimes you don't actually need a
regularization on the inner loop uh and
this may be a little bit surprising
because the interloop data set is often
really tiny but because you're
optimizing explicitly for generalization
it's going to be optimizing for at least
a part of the optimization landscape
that is uh is nicely behaved and for
which you don't get um you don't overfit
that said it may be helpful to add
regularization to this term here if
you're worried about kind of overfitting
to the tasks that you have
[Music]
so the question is it's important to
maintain this kind of distinction
between train set and test set in step
three and step four
um it is really important to have some
held out data points in step four that
are distinct from the data points that
you're using for train if you use the
same exact data points then you'll
meditate it to be able to memorize the
things that you give as input and not
actually learn the task that you care
about
um that said when you do sample a task
and when you sample the images in step
two uh it's okay to kind of mix and
match which images you use for train and
test across these different iterations
the most important thing though is that
within
um within step three and step four that
these are that you have some images in
the test set that are held up
[Music]
um
you mean after the Mediterranean process
yeah exactly yeah let's go through that
um it's a great transition so at
metatest time
foreign
we are going to be given
a task
you can call it taste and then we'll
also be given a training data set for
that task
and uh after the meta testing process
what we'll be given is we'll
um kind of at the end I guess the
the output is a
set of meta parameters Theta
and so what we're going to do
is we're going to run gradient descent
so we're basically just going to run
fine tuning starting from meta
parameters data on the training data
that we have for our new task
so our estimate for the parameters for
task J are going to correspond to Theta
minus Alpha grad Theta of
the loss function for
the the training data set
it's a good idea to use uh roughly the
same number of gradient steps in the
Inner Loop and step three as you use it
meta test time you want meta training
time and meta test time to match so that
you are preparing the method for what
will happen at metatest time
of course once you have these task
specific parameters for your test task
then you can make predictions on new
data points by given an input kind of
pass it through your function
f of Phi J to get a corresponding
prediction
now
um
this algorithm the algorithm where you
kind of learn these set of initial
parameters is referred to as model
agnostic metal learning and the reason
why it's called that is that
um nowhere in here do you see anything
about kind of a neural network
architecture or model
and
in that sense the algorithm is somewhat
agnostic to the particular architecture
that you use
you can parametrize the model the F
model here however you want and as long
as it's amenable to gradient descent you
can optimize for initialization of that
model such that gradient descent gives
you good generalization on the kinds of
tasks that you might have trained on
cool so we've already gone through the
algorithm on the board
um
again kind of the only difference from
the Black Box approach is that instead
of running the training data set through
a neural network we're going to run
gradient descent
on starting from our initial meta
parameters
the other thing that I'll note here is
or just try to emphasize here is like in
the Black Box approach
when we evaluate Phi I we're not taking
a gradient with respect to Phi I we're
taking a gradient with respect to Theta
and in this sense we're sort of treating
Phi I more as activations than as
weights we're not ever running gradient
descent on Phi I itself it's more of a
kind of a product of the inner loop
um and uh
yeah something to keep in mind
because why does it help them not train
it on Phi eye
so if you
so Phi is kind of the output of step
three and there's nothing that if you
then updated Phi I in some way
um there's nothing that then relies on
that that updated Pi eye in the process
and so it would sort of um similar to
how wind Phi I was activations it's
something that sort of gets uh kind of
wiped out at the next time you look at
the task
yeah sorry I might be ahead here but do
you have reasons to show I see that
you're the first paper
yeah I'll show some results uh
um
yeah I so I was going to go through some
math but maybe I could skip to the
results a little bit first and then
um and then go through some of the math
so this is kind of skipping ahead a
little bit but
um
there's one
so there's one paper that kind of
actually ran kind of architecture search
in addition to this algorithm and so
they were actually additionally
optimizing for
um
foreign architecture that is uh for
which this actually works well
um the kind of basic architecture on 505
shot mini image that gives you 63.1
percent which is a lot better than the
what you've been doing in homework one
if you've gotten started with homework
one
um and if you also optimize for the
architecture you can do even better than
that you can get up to 74 percent
uh the state of the art these days I
think is uh in the low 80s at this point
um and there's
uh
and well we'll get into this a little
bit later but in general these kinds of
approaches are competitive with state of
the art uh also the approaches that
we'll talk about on Wednesday are also
competitive on these image
classification problems
um but I actually also think that the
image classification benchmarks
themselves are not the most interesting
benchmarks uh because even just learning
good features can do very well on those
benchmarks and there are a lot of other
application domains where
um we're good getting good features
isn't quite enough and so we've seen
applications in drug Discovery
um as one example that can do quite well
I guess the kind of the short teal you
are though is that these kinds of
approaches can do quite well uh on metal
learning problems
yeah
I remember actually the specific
approach that they used in this paper
um but one thing that was interesting is
that instead of
um they found a fairly non-standard
architecture one that is actually quite
deep and narrow and typically deep and
narrow things are not like typically you
want enough width
um
to be able to optimize so it was kind of
interesting that it found something a
little bit different from that but you
can take a look at the if you search for
Kim and automata you'll be able to find
the paper
cool
um let's go back to some math though uh
so
one thing that actually no one has
brought up in the questions yet is that
uh this is actually going to bring up
some second order derivatives
uh and the reason for that is that you
have the inner loop here which has the
gradient with respect to Theta and you
also have the outer loop which also has
a gradient with respect to Theta
uh and so
um you might wonder like do we need a
computer Hessian uh Hessians and deep
learning are very scary because if you
have an n-dimensional parameter Vector
then the Hessian is going to be M
squared and so if you have a million
parameters that's going to be a million
squared
values in this session
also if you want to run more integrated
steps there's this question of do you
get even higher order derivatives
so
um
we're gonna do a bit of math I guess to
preface some of the math if some of you
are scared of math uh
pytorch will do all the math for you
um and so uh
don't worry too much but I think doing
looking going through the math is
actually really helpful for
understanding what happens under the
hood and what is actually the complexity
of these algorithms uh
in practice
so
um
the first thing that you need to do need
to know before we get into the math of
the the metal learning algorithms is
about Hessian Vector products
and
the cool thing about Hessian Vector
products is that um
you can actually compute them much more
cheaply than trying to compute the
Hessian itself
and in particular if we can
if we can actually compute these kind of
meta gradients without actually
um be really nice if you didn't have to
basically construct the whole Hessian in
order to compute these meta gradients
and so
in particular
one intuition that you can think of for
this is say we have some function f um
the gradient of that function is G
then
say that we are evaluating G of the
gradient of F at
X Plus Delta X
then we know that this is uh
roughly equal to
G of X Plus
um
h of x times Delta X
um so this is just a kind of typical
tailor expansion
and
from here uh
if we replace
Delta X by
[Music]
R times some vector v so R is going to
be some small value
G of X Plus RV so V is ultimately going
to be the vector that we want to be able
to compute so our goal is going to be
able to compute h of x times V
if you replace Delta x with RV then you
get this equals
G of X plus r
h of x
V
and from this form you can see that we
could actually kind of move things
around and actually solve for H of x
times V
and what we get is
h of x
V is roughly equal to
G of X Plus RV minus G of x
divided by r
can double check my math yeah
yeah
um and the cool thing about this is that
it means that you could actually
approximately compute this Hessian
Vector product with just two gradient
evaluations
and that's really awesome because that
means that we don't have to compute this
giant Hessian and this is going to be
more expensive than one gradient
evaluation of course but it's
um
but it's a lot cheaper than competing
the whole Hessian now you might wonder
okay we have this approximation sign
here uh
can we get the exact session
um and there are actually algorithms
that have the same complexity that will
also give you the exact tension I'm not
going to go into those but perlmutters
algorithm is one example of that
um but this gives you a little bit of
intuition for how we might go about
Computing these kinds of Hessian Vector
products
cool
um
yeah so that's the good news is if we
can basically compute The Meta gradient
as a Hessian Vector product then we can
compute it with only around two gradient
evaluations
now let's go back to
um let's go back to Med learning so
we um
and actually for for notational purposes
we're going to have
um
we're going to separately represent
partial versus full derivatives so I'm
going to use uh DDX to refer to full
derivatives
and the gradient of X evaluated x equals
x Prime
or X Prime equals x this will be kind of
a partial derivative
that will help keep our notation
straight a little bit
and
remember that Phi I is going to be equal
to Theta minus
let's use the full derivative here
um
d d Theta
of L
of theta comma di train
um cool so this is everything that we
had before and our goal now is going to
be to compute the gradient or The Meta
gradient in step four
um so the
the mammal objective is to
minimize with respect to Theta of the
loss of Phi I evaluated at
the test data set for that task
so this is
um the same as what's written up there
and for this we want to be able to
compute the gradient of this with
respect to Theta
and so to do that
um
let's see let's go over here so
we have d d Theta of this loss function
and now for this we can
use the chain rule
so if you remember your Calculus uh
first we're going to take the gradient
of the outer objective and then we will
differentiate
from the inner so we get the gradient of
I'm going to use Phi bar here of L
Phi bar of d i test evaluated at
Phi bar equals
Phi I
and then once we do the chain rule
on the inner loop then we just get D Phi
i d Theta because this isn't a function
of theta right here
so this is the
the kind of derivative of our loss
function with respect to Theta here
this is a row vector
so we can refer to this as V
and this is
a matrix
and then let's look a little bit more at
this Matrix right here
so this Matrix D Phi ID Theta if we look
at the definition of Phi
we see D Phi D Phi I
D Theta does anyone want to give it to
me
what do I write next
I is a matrix
Alpha
especially yeah
awesome cool I'm glad some people are
paying attention
um
and this will be with respect to D train
I
cool
um and so if we plug this expression in
to here what we're going to get is uh
this is equal to
V times I
minus Alpha
V whoops
times uh H right here so this is the
session right here
and that's great because we then get a
Hessian Vector product right here rather
than anything that has to do with the
full Hessian
can people see this is this too low
it's okay okay
cool
um so
to answer the first question
um we do get second order derivatives
here uh but we only get the session
Vector product and so in practice to
compute The Meta gradient for this
algorithm it um just requires a few
extra backward passes of your neural
network it doesn't require
anything more than that
yeah
foreign
yeah so then the question is um what
happens if you do multiple gradient
steps
so um if you do multiple gradient steps
then
your Phi I
is going to be equal to Theta minus
Alpha
d d Theta L of theta d i train this is
just the first step and then the second
step you're going to be
running a second gradient step on this
parameter Vector so if we refer to this
parameter Vector as
Theta Prime
then this next step is d
of L Theta Prime d i train
and the key thing to note here is this
second gradient step
is with respect to Theta Prime and not
with respect to
um what is Theta Prime first and then
second this isn't like
when you take a second gradient step
it's not like a second order gradient
step it's just a second gradient step in
sequence and so
um we do actually go to compute The Meta
gradient you get the same exact form as
before except now we you have a
different D Phi i d Theta
and so
um what we're going to get for the new D
Phi ID Theta is going to be the same as
before but now we're going to have a
third term which will look like
minus Alpha
times this
um
differentiated we need to differentiate
this third term by Theta and what we get
there is um something like uh
we do the chain rule again so we're
going to do
um
Theta bar Prime l
Theta bar Prime di train this is going
to be evaluated at Theta bar Prime
equals Theta Prime
times
um
D Theta Prime D Theta
uh and so
um
basically you'll get kind of these these
products of Hessians but you don't get
um you don't get anything that has a
three on it uh and that's good because
uh the higher this number is the the
next year it gets
yeah
this tells me that the three and four
are a couple degrees
that's it right so if you were to take
multiple gradient steps that just means
that the equation on step three will
have will be different instead of taking
one gradient step you will have
um
two gradient Subs like what's written
here and so the only thing that if you
take multiple inner gradient steps
that's changing is just that the
equation in three will be a little bit
different
I thought when I have already completed
the multiplication steps at the third
one
when you actually back prop through you
need to actually store all all the
intermediate parameter Vector values
because basically you can think of it as
you're gonna the kind of
the forward process of this inner loop
is running gradient descent and then to
back propagate through back prop through
that again you need to kind of back prop
through those gradient steps and so
um
the
while we don't get third order gradients
if you have a lot of inner loop steps it
will increase the amount of memory usage
um linearly and um and also increase
increase compute as well
[Music]
yeah so the question is
um is taking multiple gradient steps
worth the overhead
um for a few shot learning problems you
actually don't need a very large number
of gradient steps you could actually do
quite well with a pretty small number of
gradient steps between like one and five
gradient steps and so in practice at
least from what I've seen you don't
actually need like more than five inner
gradient steps and that ends up working
pretty well on few shot learning
problems it is also not that expensive
if you wanted to run 100 gradient steps
things get a lot more expensive and in
two weeks we're going to talk about more
advanced metal learning techniques
including ways to differentiate through
like hundreds of gradient steps uh and
doing something like this with hundreds
of integrated steps is not a great
approach
yeah
I'm just trying to connect
so these are the same as output in this
case like the
um the r here
so
um this you can think of this as a
finite difference method and R just
needs to be small here and so it's not
quite the same as Alpha
um the the most the the biggest thing is
that V is the same so V here is the same
as V there
um
and R will be separately chosen so Alpha
is just going to be the multiplier based
off of the inner learning rate
um whereas to compute this if you wanted
to use finite differences to compute
this you would separately select a small
R
um to use with finite differences
and in practice you things like Pi torch
will not use finite differences they'll
um they'll actually give you an exact
Hessian Vector product
yeah
so D train does have labels so um it
will have both the the examples and the
labels you'll only be passing the
examples into your neural network
um but then to compute the the gradient
in your inner loop you'll use the labels
there
I like which class is the most similar
to it is
and we also actually did need the labels
as well and so we were actually passing
those in to the neural network as well
and the reason why it needed that is it
needed to
um it needed to know what to output for
this for this letter
um and so it could tell you okay it's
the same class as this but then it needs
to give you a number for that class and
so we passed in the labels for that
reason for blocks as well
it's supervised yeah
yeah
um
[Music]
yeah it does still apply so
um the question is the kind of here the
label
um we sign label 0 to a in this task but
in another task you might assign a
different label to a because
um the assignment of labels to images is
is somewhat arbitrary in classification
problems and so it's also useful to
um kind of randomize that assignment
across tasks
um
yeah so for um for things like
regression problems you'll typically
keep the label intact yeah
and we'll talk a little bit more about
some of that stuff
um
in in two weeks in some of the Advanced
Metal learning topics
imagine Vector product yeah
yeah
so here's my my slide on that foreign
any other questions
oh question okay cool good
um
okay
um we also went through about a test
time already but that it's on the slide
in case you wanted a reference for that
um and the gist of it is just to run
fine tuning
um cool so yeah that was really the kind
of overall basics of optimization based
meta learning uh
now let's compare optimization based
versus Black Box meta learning and then
also talk about some challenges and
solutions we have a little bit of time
we'll also look at a case study at the
end
so
um at a conceptual level
there's a way that you can look at these
two things in a way that's quite similar
so the general form of Black Box
adaptation was to pass in the training
data set and the test input into this
big neural network and get a
corresponding label or corresponding
prediction
um for an algorithm like mammal you can
also view it in a very similar light
uh as a kind of a a computation graph
that takes his input the training data
set and a test input
um and the way that it looks like that
is essentially
um you can view it as a computation
graph that just has a gradient step
inside the computation graph so D train
and x-test are still inputs to that
overarching computation graph it's just
that it has a gradient step inside of it
where we're taking a gradient with
respect to our training data points to
get our parameters and uh and make
predictions based on those parameters
so
um
from this view you can
they they end up looking more similar
than perhaps they look like on the
previous slides uh
and also from this view it means that
you can somewhat mix and match
components of your computation graph and
there are methods that for example have
like learned in initialization but
replace the gradient update with a
learned Network
um and for example this paper does
something like that where it learns data
and it also learns this network that
kind of takes the gradient and warps it
in some way to predict a different
gradient than the actual gradient
um and this paper actually precedes the
mammal paper
and I I guess I mentioned this um as a
kind of a conceptual thing that's that's
kind of interesting
um in practice I wouldn't recommend
using this algorithm it's uh
it's a little bit more complicated and
tends to not work as well as actually
just using the gradient
um but it's something that I think is
useful to know conceptually
um cool and then we'll also look at this
again on on Wednesday when we look at a
third class of approaches
now
um now let's actually look at how these
algorithms perform in practice so
in general both of them can represent a
variety of learning algorithms
um but one thing that's nice about the
optimization based meta learning
algorithms is that at meta test time
you're like literally just running fine
tuning
and so even if you don't actually have a
very good set of meta parameters fine
tune should still give you something
that improves on the the parameter
Vector that you have
whereas if you just throw something into
a recurrent neural network you can't
really
um
you can't really expect it to
necessarily give you something
reasonable if the data set is out of
distribution from the tasks that I saw
before
and so we can explicitly test this
um and so we're going to compare an
optimization based algorithm mammal with
two black box algorithms called Snail
and meta Networks
and specifically we're going to look at
omnigot image classification and we're
going to look at performance as you vary
the task
and in particular the first thing we're
going to look at is all the algorithms
are just meta trained on the original
Omni glot data set
but then we evaluated them on tasks that
had uh digits that were warped
and so they were all trained on kind of
the center line so they're going to do
the best at the center but then as you
warp the
um as you warped the characters more and
more the performance will get worse
because it's more out of distribution
and so what we find here is that an
algorithm like mammal actually is able
to generalize much better to these odd
distribution tasks compared to something
like the black box metal Learners
because it has this kind of structure of
running gradient descent embedded within
it and it's just running fine-tuning at
test time
um we can also look at this on a second
task this is we're kind of warping the
size of the digits and here we see a
similar Trend where the optimization
based algorithm is better able to
extrapolate
um yeah
I think can you as a baseline can you
fine-tune the black box modeling
yeah yeah so if you have a black box
metal learner that's actually outputting
parameters then you could also fine tune
those parameters a little bit and you
would expect that to do a little bit
better than if you didn't fine-tune
um both of these approaches snail and
meta networks are not actually
outputting us a single set of parameters
but you could sort of like fine-tune the
last part of the RNN
um and in principle that should improve
it a little bit I suspect that it may it
may not improve it all the way up to the
purple line but I suspect it would
improve it a little bit
yeah
um what critics came with the rapid form
inaccuracy which comes in this game and
not so much
yeah so the question is why is it um
dropping more rapidly for the scale
versus the shift
um the
I should say that the x-axis on these
two plots are not very comparable uh one
is in is in like scale and one of his is
in radians and so
um if for example you zoomed out more on
the radiance plot to show a wider range
I would expect it to drop off more
quickly
um I also think that as you make a digit
smaller and smaller it's probably a
little bit harder for the neural network
to read
um than the larger one and so that's I
expect why we see more of a drop off on
the left side than on the right side but
that's somewhat speculative
um
what is the underlying small
architecture so um for Mammal it's a
four layer convolutional Network
um with I think like 32 filters
something like that per layer
um
and it's kind of a standard architecture
that's been used in multiple Works uh
whereas for sale and meta networks the
architecture is a little bit more
specific to the method
um because it's a kind of a non-model
agnostic method it's kind of um yeah and
so snow was the one that used the
interleaved
um
the interleaved convolutions and
attention layers
the scale in the shifting Park
um
if you ask me if the convolution layer
is helpful
understanding variance in the data
distribution which is a scale of the
shift whereas this nail I guess just use
RNs right
um so snail so snail was using
um
I can't remember if if there was I'm
pretty sure there was a backbone that
was convolution based
um and likewise for meta networks I
can't remember the specifics uh of it
unfortunately but I'm pretty sure it is
using that
um and I should mention and emphasize
here that all these were only trained on
this scale and so they were not they
didn't see any data at different scales
and different Shears of the digit
cool
um so
the um we see that we like the structure
of gradient descent is helping us
generalize to out of distribution tasks
um now you might wonder if this
structure comes at a cost because
the um
maybe for example by embedding gradient
descent we don't have as much expressive
power in terms of the algorithms the
learning procedures that we can
represent
and it turns out that you can actually
theoretically show that if you have a
deep neural network
um the kind of mammal function of
running gradient just one step of
gradient descent can actually
approximate any function of the training
data set and the the test input so it
can sort of approximate any learning
algorithm
um although it does make
um some non-trivial assumptions well it
assumes that the learning rate is
non-zero that the data points are are
unique and that the loss function
gradient does not lose information about
the label
um but the really the strongest
assumption is that the network needs to
be uh extremely deep for this sort of
result to hold and you can get more
expressive power with the RNN like
approaches with
um with a smaller neural network
what that means just very approximately
is if you is if you have one loss
function that
um that looks like this versus a loss
function that looks like this if you
just look at the gradient of this
function
you don't actually know where you are on
the line at all and so that doesn't tell
you
um you know what your prediction is but
it doesn't tell you what the label is
relative to your prediction
um and so it doesn't hold for L1 loss
functions but it does hold for things
like L2 and cross entropy loss
yeah why is it that these points in the
this is be unique
a little bit getting into details that
aren't super important but the um the
gist is that if you have uh duplicates
of data points and you want it to give
you different
by eyes for different numbers of
duplicates in the in the data set it's
hard to
um it's hard to understand how many
duplicates there are in the gradient for
example if you think about the gradient
of
two data points versus the gradient of
five data points that are identical the
gradient is the same because just
averaging across them and so it's not
going to
um The Learning algorithm isn't going to
be able to differentiate between
um
but it's not gonna be able to count the
number of data points you have basically
yeah
you expect me or is there any uh point
to the in using Black Books
yeah
um let's go through some of the
challenges and solutions and then well
I'll talk about I'll get it you need to
full depth of that on Wednesday
um but I'll also talk more about the
pros and cons after we go through some
of the challenges and solutions
so
um one one reason to not use these kinds
of optimization based methods is that
sometimes this sort of bi-level
optimization can be somewhat unstable
because you have an optimization inside
another optimization
um and there are ways to try to
stabilize the process
um one way to stabilize it is actually
to
to give it a little bit more expressive
power don't just learn the
initialization but also learn the
learning rate uh and this has been shown
to at least in practice lead to an
easier outer optimization
there's also approaches that try to only
optimize a subset of the parameters in
the Inner Loop for example you could
choose to only optimize the last layer
in the Inner Loop or choose to only
optimize like the batch storm parameters
in your inner loop or something like
that
um
and then there's also some work that
showed that if you um
that if you have a different learning
rate in a different platform statistics
per gradient step in the Inner Loop that
can also help stabilize things because
if they're coupled then they um whenever
you have basically the same value for
something it can cause those values to
sort of fight during the optimization
process and not find a good uh happy
medium
um
and then
I don't want to go into too much depth
in this but there's also approaches that
try to kind of introduce a sort of
context variable that instead of only
optimizing for the parameters of this
neural network you can essentially uh
add a variable that's kind of part of
theta here as part of the network you
can sort of think of this as like kind
of like the zi that we saw in multitask
learning that you're optimizing as well
as the other parameters and this can
also
um
uh kind of increase the expressive power
of the meta Optimizer and um and in
practice leads to to better results as
well
um we're giving this just as an overview
if you want to dive a little bit deeper
into
um things that can help these algorithms
work better in practice
cool um so yeah range of simple tricks
that can help the optimization a lot
and then the second main challenge I
want to talk about is that uh
if you have one or a few inner gradient
steps it's very easy to differentiate
through that but if you have a lot of
inner gradient steps it becomes very
compute intensive and very memory
intensive
and there are also a few tricks for
trying to address this
um the first trick is a bit of a hack
and it's actually something that I
discovered because of a bug in
tensorflow
uh and in particular
um the first time that I implemented
the mammal algorithm
um it turned out that tensorflow didn't
properly implement this uh this term and
it just silently basically set this to
be the identity
um
and it turns out that actually if you
said it to be the identity it actually
works uh
some of the time uh and so
for for a simple image classification
tasks you can actually and it that's not
the identity by the way
um yeah and so yeah it turns out to
actually work in some cases there's
another paper that explicitly proposed
this sort of first order method as well
um and so if you do approximate as the
identity you actually you don't have any
second order terms and uh and it can
work well on simple problems
um in other problems I've found that it
uh it doesn't work well uh at all
um not quite uh the I mean tensorflow
has since fixed this issue this was uh
very early days in 20 early 2017
um yeah but since then both and actually
the early days of Pi torch they also
didn't have their second order
derivatives properly implemented as well
so
um yeah
so it's
it's basically saying that the Lost
landscape around Phi is very similar to
The Lost landscape around Theta I
I don't think we know why it works
um although my guess would be something
that it has to do with the optimization
landscape being well conditioned
um but yeah we don't fully know why this
works
0 therefore I or
yeah so this was being set to
um to zero yeah
I don't remember the exact details of
the bug uh but it was something like I
think it was something like basically
the Hessian wasn't implemented or
something and it was silently returning
zero rather than throwing an error
we don't know
it's an observation yeah
um another thing that you can do is if
you don't want to back propagate through
many integrating steps of the whole
network if you only optimize the last
layer of Weights then this can actually
be very cheap
um and
um there are a number of papers that
have done this that actually get quite
strong results and in some of these
cases you can actually compute the
um you can compute potentially the last
layer in closed form and that yeah that
has a number of benefits this works
especially well in settings where in
like image settings where learning
features are a big part of the problem
um cool and then there's also
um something called the implicit value
theorem that is actually pretty cool it
allows you to differentiate the meta
gradient without actually
differentiating through the optimization
path
um we might talk about this a little bit
in some of the Advanced Metal learning
lectures uh but I more mention it here
as a reference in case you're interested
in digging deeper into that yeah
so in um basically yeah in step three
you only optimize the inner loop and
then step four you optimize the whole
network such that
um basically optimize for features such
that optimizing the inner loop gives you
a um good performance
yeah
you don't fine-tuning different parts of
of the network you could also have
something where you fine-tune the last
layer for some tasks and fine tune the
first layer for other tasks although
then there's this
um you have to actually select which
layer to adapt for different tasks
um there's also a paper that actually
optimizes everything but the last layer
and they actually found pretty good
results with that uh
I'm not exactly sure how they came up
with it
it's called boil if you want to look it
up
but yeah you could imagine something
like that
cool and then I already showed this
slide but um there's also some works
that I've looked at architectures for
this kind of bi-level optimization
um and have found that actually
sometimes deeper and narrow
architectures can work pretty well
um
and yeah that's the gist of it so
um the takeaway here is that we're
constructing this bi-level optimization
problem
um in terms of the pros and cons
one thing that's really nice about it is
it has this sort of positive inductive
bias at the start of meta learning and
what I mean by that is before you do any
meta learning you're already running
gradient descent on your training data
set in the Inner Loop
uh and that means that you already have
a pretty good starting point for
learning from data
and in contrast to Black Box approaches
Black Box approaches are starting with a
randomly initialized recurrent neural
network and so when you pass in a data
set into that randomly initialized
neural network it doesn't have any sort
of inductive bias at the beginning that
will give you
um that will actually do anything
remotely like learning at the start of
initialization
um because of this it tends to
extrapolate a little bit better because
you're embedding gradient descent
because you're running fine tuning
um and it's also quite expressive if you
have a deep enough neural network
and it's model agnostic
um the downside is that does typically
require a second order optimization
which can be computationally it's a
little bit certainly a little bit more
expensive than other approaches
especially the approaches we'll talk
about on Wednesday
um and so this leads to more compute and
memory usage
cool
um we have six minutes so I think I will
go through this this case study we'll
also look at some more case studies on
um on Wednesday this week
um so this was actually some work done
by some folks at tum and also some folks
at Stanford Sherry
um was actually a PhD student at
Stanford she graduated I think last year
and is now starting as a professor at
MIT uh
and this is some work that they did on
trying to do land cover classification
and the motivation is that if you have a
satellite image it's useful to be able
to predict how the land is being used
this can be used for urban planning for
understanding how things are changing
over time
um but it's very expensive to label
these satellite images as you might
imagine
um and so labeling data is really
expensive and different regions look
different and have different land use
proportions and so this means that if
you train a model on one part of the
world and then try to apply that model
to other parts of the world it may not
generalize well to
all parts of the world
and so what they were looking at is
um they had croplands from multiple
different countries and they framed this
as a meta learning problem where
different tests correspond to different
regions of the world
and so what they wanted to be able to do
is for a new region of the world that
they didn't have labels for yet they
wanted to label a small amount of data
for that region and then get a good
segment to our classifier for that
region of the world that can basically
fill in the rest of the labels
um and so you can sort of think of this
as uh this is a diagram from their paper
where you try to find a good set of
initial parameters such that when you
fine tune on a new region of the world
you're able to quickly get a model that
can
accurately segment
satellite images from that part of the
world
um so they looked at two different data
sets one of the data sets had Geographic
metadata in it and so they were able to
separate out kind of explicitly separate
out new regions of the world and so blue
dark blue is metatrain light blue is
meta validation tasks and orange is meta
test tasks
um
and kind of as an example of a
of a two-way two-shot classification
task they're trying to classify if a
square is Forest or croplands and
um
and so they're given that and then they
have two examples per class of what
those parts of the land look like
um and then this also has a second data
set where they're looking at or they
didn't have any kind of geographic
metadata and so they use clustering to
try to guess the region of the world and
separate things out into metatraining
meta validation and meta test and here
they're doing a kind of a segmentation
task
um where they were basically the support
set corresponded to one small square and
then the queries that corresponded to
the other squares
cool
um and so they
[Music]
um
they were comparing uh randomly
initialized random initialization so
they're trading from scratch on a small
amount of data from that new region
they also compared that to pre-training
on all of the data they had so far and
then fine-tuning on the target task and
lastly they compared to the manual
algorithm that we talked about today
um and what we see is uh here is the
results on the first data set and there
this is the performance or the accuracy
of land cover classification as you
increase the number of data points on
the target task
um first we see that random
initialization isn't able to do very
well because it doesn't use any other
data using a pre-trained network is able
to do a lot better especially with less
data and then mammal is able to do if
you have one or more data points from
the target region is able to do uh even
better than a pre-trained neural network
one benefit to the pre-trained neural
network is it can actually already do
decent classification Justin without any
additional data from the new region um
and so that's why the dark blue is above
the orange and the light green at zero
um and then likewise on the Deep Globe
data set
um they looked at both a random split
and a harder clustered split
um here uh the results are similar on
the clustered split um on the random
split they actually found that the
pre-trained model was able to do quite
well which makes sense because the kind
of the pre-training data and the target
data
um you're gonna basically have more data
points that look more similar across the
kind of pre-trained data and the target
data
cool and then if you're interested in
like looking at this more I'd encourage
you to take a look at the paper
um here's just kind of yeah just one
example of a fairly real world problem
of using this kind of approach
um
cool um so that's it for today uh we
covered the basics of optimization-based
meta learning we talked about how it
compared with black box metal learning
um on Wednesday we're going to be
talking about our last class of last
type of metal learning method
um non-parametric keyshot learning
methods then next week we'll talk about
unsupervised pre-training and the
following week we'll talk about more
advanced metal learning topics
um yeah and as a reminder submit your
project form and your homework on
Wednesday